this guy is usually seen in the
background of pictures but he's one of
the most successful people in the world
of pop music he's written top hits for
Britney Spears the Backstreet Boys Katy
Perry and so many more
only two other people have had more
songwriting success John Lennon and Paul
McCartney
Max Martin is effectively the king of
pop music but what's the secret to his
incredible success
one place to look to answer that
question might be the data Behind the
Music
[Music]
like all good data stories this one
starts by opening Excel we have a data
set with
1124 rows 66 columns and a vast amount
of information about music all compiled
with Little Help from our friend Chris
my name is Christopher De La Riva and
I'm a musician he's also a data
journalist I do like analyzing data
Chris has looked back through the
history of music to create his data set
it looks at every number one hit on the
Billboard top 100 charts since 1958. I
just added more and more information the
song the artists the songwriters the
label it was on and slowly this data set
became humongous all of Max Martin's
number one hits are in here but with so
much data where do you start
a rare on-camera interview with Martin
when he won the polar music prize gave
us an idea if you compare pop songs when
you grew up with pop songs written right
now what are the major differences
the intros were usually longer back then
could short intros be one of the keys to
Martin's success
first we put all of his number one songs
on a chart showing the year they charted
and length of their introduction you
could point to Baby One More Time by
Britney Spears and then you can point to
blinding Lights by the weekend all in
between there's just hit after hit after
hit 24 of them to be exact and their
average intro length is just nine
seconds like his 2010 hit with pink
Raise Your Glass
it only takes nine seconds to get to
this part
off the lights pretty quick
but how does that compare with the hits
when Max was young let's go back to the
future to 1985 when he was just 14 years
old
and the Power of Love by Huey Lewis in
the news topped the charts
it's a song that embodies the sound of
the 80s
partly because it was a major player in
the trend of hit songs featuring in
films but also because its intro ends
here
[Music]
21 seconds in
which also happens to be the average
length of the intros for all of the
number one hits from the 1980s
that's a lot longer than Max's hits
but it's not
earning success with brevity all told
the average length of a song intro by
The 2020s was 48 shorter than in the
1980s so what's Driven this downward
Trend that Max seems to have been
particularly good at exploiting
we wondered whether the changing shape
of songs might reflect other changes
like how people listen to them for
decades pop music was all about the
single but by the 1980s we were well
into the era of the album long playing
records and later CDs were the focus for
fans and writers alike from 2000 digital
distribution of Music began to take over
with the arrival of iPods and MP3
players the trend towards shorter intros
accelerated with the Advent of streaming
platforms like YouTube and Spotify
these brought access to seemingly
infinite Choice A Renewed focus on
individual songs and for the hit writers
one pretty compelling reason to cut to
the chase
there are Financial incentives with
streaming you don't get paid unless your
song is played for more than 30 seconds
songwriters have to get to the point
quickly
if they want to make a ball as Max
Martin well knows let's look at his hit
can't stop the feeling
[Music]
the catchy vocals hit within seven
seconds
but another job hits at 25 seconds
by 30 seconds the point at which Max and
his team will get paid if the listener
stays around there's no way you're
skipping
Max we can't stop the feeling that we've
uncovered one of your secrets to top the
charts it pays to be in tune with how
your audience is listening
[Music]
hi I'm Caitlin and I'm a producer here
on the film steam at The Economist our
data team at The Economist every week
writes stories called graphic detail
they're text pieces that focus on one
piece of data and they visualize and
analyze that data to tell important
stories we're keen to Showcase more of
that journalism here on our YouTube
channel if you click the link it will
take you to all of those graphic detail
stories we'd love you to have a read and
let us know what you think about them in
the comments below but in the meantime
don't forget to subscribe